wokeness isn't a silly distraction it's
deadly
[Music]
serious there were two news stories that
struck me last week in that they
illustrate perfectly why many of us have
been concerned about the radical
progressivism which has taken over our
media political and cultural Elites my
principal critique of this ideology is
that it encourages people to prioritize
their subjective feelings about doing
good and being tolerant over the reality
of how the world actually works and
these two stories demonstrate the
fallacy of the work worldview and the
terrible consequences its application
has for the rest of us first was the
story of a Jamaican man who was saved
from deportation last year by a
passenger Mutiny aboard a British
Airways flight led by Cambridge graduate
Hannah Gaffrey Brave passengers
prevented the Injustice of his removal
from the country after a protracted
legal battle Miss Gaffrey posted proudly
on Twitter that she and other passengers
refused ref used to sit down before
takeoff and described receiving advice
from detention action a left-wing human
rights charity if Miss Gaffrey and her
fellow human rights campaigners had
bothered to inquire as to why the man
was being removed from the country they
may have discovered that Lawrence Morgan
was being deported because he'd been
convicted of a whole host of gun related
charges including taking part in a
shootout with other gangsters in which
another man was brutally killed in open
broad daylight Mr Morgan it turns out
was a violent drug dealing gangster and
the only reason he hadn't been deported
faster was that he claimed his life
would be in danger in Jamaica from other
gangsters of course the Second Story
which caught my eye was the report that
the British government has banned the
islamist group isbut teria the group's
stated aim is the reestablishment of the
Islamic caliphate and the imposition of
sharia law on the world why did the band
strike me as telling because the fact
that his but teria wasn't already banned
shows the absurdity of the approach our
society is taking do you know which
countries banned hisb teria long before
Britain did Indonesia the most populous
Muslim nation in the world every Arab
country except Yemen Lebanon and the UAE
every Muslim country in Central Asia the
group is banned in Bangladesh and
Pakistan in other words Muslim countries
are less tolerant of islamist extremists
than we are why because they're able to
speak plainly about the threat they pose
and we're not in a now viral clip the
UAE foreign Minister shik Abdullah Bin
Zed speaking years ago warned Western
countries that their failure of
leadership and obsession with political
correctness his words not mine would sew
the seeds of extremism there will come a
day that we will see far more radical
extremist and terrorists coming out of
Europe because of lack
of decision making trying to be
politically correct
or assuming that they know the Middle
East and they know Islam and they know
the others far better than we do and I'm
I'm sorry but that's pure
ignorance there is evil in the world
there are people who do not belong in
our countries there are people who wish
us harm no man of be kind and don't look
back in anger will stop them and the
problem with wokeness is that it trains
otherwise good people to fail to see
this before you go let me take a minute
to recommend a longevity supplement by
Verso in our recent interview with Tim
Urban he said we should be talking about
longevity and Longevity science
researchers like the biologist David
Sinclair have recently made some
fascinating discoveries on how to
mitigate or even slow down aging
altogether and that's why I'm using
Verso Verso is a company that translates
these incredible scientific
breakthroughs into products that hold
the potential to increase your longevity
and one of their products that I take
every day is cell beinging cell beinging
helps combat aging by increasing
something called NAD Plus in your body
now NAD is arguably the most important
molecule in your body high NAD levels
improve your metabolism repair damaged
DNA and increase energy production in
your brain immune system and muscles but
as you grow old your body's NAD levels
go down and you can't take NAD as a
supplement because it's too big for your
cells to absorb that's why y Verso cell
being contains nmn resveratol and TMG
these three molecules work together to
increase NAD plus levels if you want to
read more about this check out the
scientific research Linked In the
description of this video plus Verso
publishes third party testing on every
batch of its products to guarantee that
you're getting exactly what you're
paying for so if you want to join me you
can get 15% off by going to
v.o that's
v.o and use our code trigger to save 15%
off your order and if you enjoyed this
video make sure to check out the street
interviews I did with people at a
massive Pro Palestine rally here in
[Music]
London